good morning believe nation today's
message is life is unpredictable over to
you Lloyd Blankfein life is quick I'm
sure all of you have your lives planned
out and the one thing it can absolutely
guarantee is it won't work out that way
because just things happen first of all
the world changes and the world evolve
so whatever plans you making it's based
on a static world that won't be there
because things will happen and you'll
change or maybe you won't even change
maybe you just miss identifying yourself
now and you don't know and which is a
perfectly appropriate way to be when you
know you're young or my age cuz you know
who knows so what do you think you know
what this actually is very much to talks
about how I've lived my life or how
where I've gotten quick background I
originally when I went to university I
studied psychology to be a couples
therapist because I was really obsessed
relationships and wanting to help
couples and then as I was going through
university I changed my career path
completely and I wanted to be a cop so I
did all the testing I did all of that
and then when I started dating my
current fiance who I met at CVS that
career path chain changed into sales and
then to hear now the you know write up
in charge of operations for TDs teaching
at TDS so a lot of small moving parts
will happen the one thing that I do say
is life is unpredictable but you know
all these career paths consistently
showed that I wanted to work with people
that I want to make up the difference in
people's lives whether that was a cop
whether that was a psychologist even in
sales I helped a lot of businesses and
sales make sure that they save money and
they stay in business with teaching and
all of that so life is unpredictable I
believe in that I'm a perfect example of
that because I would never have imagined
where I am now six years ago but
consistently it's like your core things
as long as you know who you are or what
you're strong at what you're good at
whatever life throws at you you can be
flexible enough to sort of you know mold
yourself into that while staying true to
yourself my thoughts on this are one as
entrepreneurs you need to change your
business as you grow and evolve as a
person you're going to become more and
more interested in other things as you
get older and a lot of entrepreneurs get
stuck in a
right where you just keep doing the same
thing over and over and over again and
you don't change your business as you
change who you are and that's when
people hit these blocks and you stagnant
you don't continue to grow and you need
to always make sure your business is a
reflection of who you are as a person or
or sell it and move on to something else
if your business can't change with you
the other thing I would add to it is I
think a lot of people are just too
afraid to take risks on things because
they're looking for certainty and I look
at I look at what we've done here at TDS
some of the things I've worked out
really well and some of them have it
right the thing that we're pissed at
right now is we've spent three months
working on a new technology back-end for
our school that just hasn't worked out
and it was my call to start to say hey I
want to try the system out I think it's
gonna push us forward to improve our
systems and our administrator it's worse
than we were when we started and so
we're going back to where we were before
and that's like massively painful right
to be behind where you were and then go
back to what you're doing before but
sometimes it doesn't work out and and be
okay with that
right that's not going to prevent me
from taking the nest risks and the next
idea and moving forward in the next
project that I have in mind because a
lot of things that we have done have
worked out and I think too many people
are caught up on previous failures that
then make them afraid to go out and take
that nests next risk so it's maybe not
totally related to life is unpredictable
but that's what I'm vibing so that's
what you get so the question of the day
today is how do you find order in chaos
leave in the comments below a join the
discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and we'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of espresso
Peevy